>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Here to read from "The Girl who
Drank the Moon" is Kelly Barnhill.
[ Applause ]
>> Kelly Barnhill: Oh, my.
I'm very concerned I might trip.
That's all right.
If I trip, it won't be the first
time that I have fallen off
of a stage because I am very
klutzy, so I, I apologize right now.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Kelly Barnhill.
I write books with magic in them.
So, before we begin, I know
we have 25 minutes together,
and I don't want to have me
talk too long because I know
that you guys have
a lot of questions.
Part of being a kid is that you're
basically composed of questions.
I know a lot of you have questions
about how books get written.
about where ideas come from.
I know you have questions
about how you can come back
to the same story day
after day after day
and make something happen again.
So, I, what I want you to do for me
right now is save your questions up.
Because I want, I would, my
favorite part of any presentation is
when you guys ask questions
and I answer them
and we can talk a little
bit about it, okay?
Now, before we begin, just so
I can get a sense of grades,
how many of you guys
are in third grade?
How many third graders do we have?
Can you raise your hand?
Oh! We have one third
grader, awesome.
Two? That's cool.
Three third graders?
Third grade is a, four, five, wow!
Third grade is a really good grade.
Well now, I remember
being in third grade.
It was the first time I
learned about Ancient Egypt
and it was super cool
and kind of blew my mind.
How many of you guys
are fourth graders?
How many? Ah, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve, whoa!
And even more than 12.
There's a lot of fourth
graders here today.
I love fourth graders.
Part of my job, one of
my many jobs that I have,
is I go around to the state
of Minnesota where I live
and I do creative writing workshops.
I do story writing
workshops with kids.
And I will say there
is something magical
that happens in fourth grade.
Fourth graders, I think,
are actually magical.
And they write amazing stories.
Every time, no matter what
kind of school I'm in,
fourth graders are magic.
How many of you guys
are in fifth grade?
Awesome! Oh, my gosh, so, um, the
fifth grade is an amazing grade
because you guys are about
to start something brand new.
Right? You're about to
become something else.
You're about to become
middle schoolers.
How many of you are
in middle school?
Awesome. Well done.
You guys, this is awesome.
Okay, so, this is my book.
It's called "The Girl
who Drank the Moon".
I love writing books
with magic in it.
This is a story about
a 500-year-old witch
and a poetry-quoting
swamp monster who may
or may not be as old as the world.
And a perfectly tiny dragon, who
suffers from delusions of grandeur
and he thinks he's so giant,
he's bigger than a house,
but actually he's so small
that he fits in your pocket.
And they all have to
raise a magical baby.
That's not really what
the story is about.
It sort of is, though.
I wanted to write a story about a
place where, every year, every year,
they participate in a
terrible, terrible crime.
This town, it's called
"The Protectorate".
It is sandwiched between a bog
that covers half of the world,
you cannot cross, and on one
side, and on the other side,
there is a very, very
dangerous forest.
It is so dangerous that it is
very difficult to get through it.
And what the people of the
Protectorate believe is
that the reason why that
forest is dangerous is
because there is a
witch in the woods.
Yes, they say, yes.
There is a witch in the woods.
And the only way to keep
that witch from coming
and destroying them all is that they
have to, every year, take a baby,
the youngest baby in
the Protectorate,
and leave it in the forest
for the witch to take.
So, they have to sacrifice
a baby every year.
And because of this, because
of this terrible crime
and because everyone is complicit
in it, the entire Protectorate is,
it's a sorrowful, terrible place.
They live in this cloud of sorrow.
And because of that sorrow, nobody
really seems to notice the fact
that the council of elders
owns everything in the town
and everyone else has nothing.
And nobody seems to
notice that the council
of elders runs everything
in the town.
And nobody else in the town
has any kind of power at all.
Now, the council of elders,
they don't believe in the witch.
They never have.
For them, it's a convenient fiction.
Unpleasant, yes, unpleasant.
But it's convenient for
them, because it allows them
to maintain this life that
they've always had, right?
Now, what the council
of elders do not know is
that there really is a witch.
Her name is Xan.
She's 500 years old, and every
year she comes to the same place
in the forest and, once again,
somebody has left a baby, a baby,
just sitting right
there in the forest.
And she can't just leave the baby
there, because the baby will die.
So, she does what all of us
would do if we saw a baby
that has been abandoned
in the woods.
What would we do?
We'd save the baby, right?
We'd save the baby, obviously.
And so, she does what any
sensible witch would do.
She gathers the baby up and
over the years she has taken
certain precautions.
She has brought a blanket,
because, well,
I'm probably going to find a baby.
I always find one every year.
She brings a blanket
to wrap the baby up.
She brings a bottle of
goat's milk to feed the baby.
Now, the forest is very
dangerous and it's very dangerous
because it's a volcanic landscape.
And so, it's very tricky
to get across.
Xan knows how, because of cleverness
and know-how and also magic, too.
And, on the other side of the
forest, there's a bunch of cities
that are called the free cities
that are really pleasant places
and they don't have
bizarre, terrible things
that they do every single year.
And so, she decides that she's going
to take the baby across the forest
and find the perfect
family for each baby.
And she carries the baby across
and she feeds them the goat's
milk whenever the tummy gets empty
and when the goat's milk runs out,
she does what any sensible
witch would do.
She reaches her hands
up to the night sky
and she gathers starlight
as light as gossamer.
Well, I can see from your faces
that you already know why.
I mean, starlight is
an excellent baby food.
Ask any witch, right?
And so, by the time she gets to
the other side of the forest,
these babies are star-filled
and blessed and they are funny
and clever and kind and they
make wonderful daughters and sons
and wonderful brothers and
sisters, and they grow up to be good
at what they do and
excellent members
of the community and
wonderful parents.
And they are successful.
And when they die, they die rich.
This has literally been
happening for 300 years.
Now, as this story opens,
certain things don't
happen according to plan.
Things don't happen
in the normal way.
Number one, a mother
fights for her baby.
She fights and she
fights and she fights.
And she kicks and she scratches
and she pulls people's hair out
and she says, you do not
get to take my child.
Well, everybody says she is crazy!
She must be insane.
And so, they lock her up in
the tower as the mad woman.
And they take the baby and
they leave it in the forest.
Now, when Xan arrives, oh, sorry.
Another thing that happens that
is not particularly usual is
that there is a boy who's 12
years old, and his name is Antain.
And Antain is an elder in training.
But he bears witness
to this terrible scene
of this mother fighting
for her baby.
Normally, people just
give their babies up.
That's just what everybody does.
But Antain sees this, and he,
all by himself in trying to hide
from the adults that he is crying.
And he's so terrified and
horrified by what he's seeing
that that becomes a
question in his heart.
Why? Why do we do this?
And can we do something else?
And as he grows, that question in
his heart is going to get bigger
and bigger and bigger and then
it's going to turn into a plan.
Okay. The third thing that
happens is that Xan the witch,
she comes across this baby and she
wraps the baby up and she notices
that the baby has a
birthmark on her forehead.
Just in the shape of
a crescent moon.
And as, and it's just
a random birthmark.
There's nothing special about it.
But Xan has one, too.
She has that same birthmark.
And this has never
happened to her before.
She's never seen a baby
who kind of looks like her.
And she feels this sense
of kinship with the baby.
And so she finds herself taking
the journey very, very slowly,
because she wants to show
the baby things and she wants
to sing the baby a song and she
wants to tell the baby a story.
And she just wants to
look in the baby's eyes.
She's got big, black eyes.
She's a beautiful baby.
And as she goes, she is
giving the baby more and more
and more starlight every night.
And the baby becomes more and
more and more star-filled.
But what she doesn't notice is
that the moon is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger,
because that's what moons do.
They wax and they wane, right?
And then, one night, the
moon is all the way full.
And Xan doesn't notice and she
reaches up to gather starlight
and she accidentally gets moonlight
instead, and it is sticky and sweet
on her fingers and she
feeds it to the baby.
Well, I can see from your faces
that you already can
tell the problem, here.
If a witch gives full
moonlight to a baby,
she enmagics that baby, permanently.
It can't be undone.
This is serious and old,
old magic and so now,
you've got a baby that's
filled all the way,
filled to bursting with magic.
And so, anything could happen
with a baby that is this magical.
She could turn her caregiver
into a bunny and she does.
She could make the cradle fly.
She could burst things into flames.
She has no idea what she is doing.
How many of you have
ever met a baby before?
How much sense does a baby have?
Not very much, huh?
And so, she can't just
leave this baby with anybody
because she is dangerous.
And so Xan decides to bring the
baby home and bring the baby up.
So, she goes to her home in
the forest where she lives
with a poetry quoting
swamp monster who may
or may not be as old as the world.
And a perfectly tiny dragon who
suffers from delusions of grandeur.
And they become a very loving,
albeit very strange, little family.
But here's the thing about children.
And you guys are all kids,
so you know this already.
Children grow.
And as they grow, the questions
inside of them get bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger.
And so, in the Protectorate,
we've got Antain who starts
out to be twelve years old
at the beginning, and then,
eventually becomes a young man.
And his question of
why, why do we do this?
That is going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger
until he has a family of his own
and has some really big
problems in front of him.
And Luna, Luna, the
girl who drank the moon.
Luna with this incredible
magic inside her,
she is going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger.
And the questions about her life and
why it is that she has these dreams
of a black haired woman
standing at the roof of a house
with her hair flying all around her
yelling, "She is here, she is here,
she is here!", and meanwhile,
there's the madwoman in the tower
who is making maps of impossibly
strange places that also say,
"She is here, she is
here, she is here!".
And as the story progresses,
all of these threads
start to come together.
So, that is my book.
I was going to read
you, just 109 minutes?
Okay, I have 10 minutes left.
I'm going to read you just a
tiny bit and then I'm going
to have questions from you guys,
because I know you
guys have questions.
Okay, that sound good?
One of the things that is fun
for a fantasy author who used
to be a theology major
is that you actually get
to make a brand new world and you
get to write things like this.
Where is it?
Oh here we go.
In the beginning, there was
bog and bog and bog and bog.
There were no people,
there were no fish.
There were no birds or beasts
or mountains or forests or sky.
The bog was everything.
And everything was the bog.
The muck of the bog ran from one
edge of reality to the other,
it curved and warbled through time.
There were no words,
there was no learning,
there was no music
or poetry or thought.
There was just the sigh of the
bog and the crick of the bog
and the endless rustle of the reeds.
But, the bog was lonely.
It wasnted eyes with
which to see the world.
It wanted a strong back
with which to carry itself
from place to place to place.
It wanted hands to touch and legs
to walk and a mouth that could sing.
And so, the bog created a body.
A great beast that walked out of the
bog on its own stong, boggy legs.
And the beast was the bog,
and the bog was the beast.
And the beast loved the bog.
And the bog loved the beast.
Just as a person loves the image
of himself in a still pool of water
and looks upon it with tenderness.
The beast's chest was full of
warm and life-giving compassion.
He felt the shine of
love radiating ourward
and he wanted words to
exspress how he felt.
And so, there were words.
And then the beast wanted those
words to fit together just so,
just to explain his meaning.
He opened his mouth,
and a poem came out.
Round and yellow, yellow
and round, the beast said.
And then the sun was born,
shining just overhead.
Blue and white and black and gray,
and a burst of color at
dawn, the beast sang.
And then the sky was born.
The creak of wood and the softness
of moss and the rustle and whisper
of green and green
and green and green.
And then, there were forests.
Everything you see,
everything you know,
was brought into being by the bog.
The bog loved us and
we loved the bog.
[ Applause ]
There are microphones
right over there,
so if anybody has a
question, I want to answer it.
It will have to go way down,
because you guys are short.
Hi!
>> Hi.
>> Kelly Barnhill:
What's your question, hon?
>> I have two.
>> Kelly Barnhill: Okay.
Go ahead.
>> Why did you decide
to write this book?
>> Kelly Barhnill: Oh,
really good question.
Why did I decide to write this book?
Well, I was out for a run one day,
and I had a vision
of a swamp monster.
And he had four arms
and wide, damp jaws.
And eyes that moved
independently of each other.
And he was holding a daisy in
one hand, and he recited a poem.
And it was actually the last
poem that is in the book.
YOu know, there's all
kinds of poems in the book.
And the very last poem
was from that one day,
and I did not change
a single word of it.
And so, I ran home, and I
wrote the poem down on a card.
And then, I wrote on
the back, Swamp Monster.
And then I got a box, because
all of my books start with a box,
and i put the card into the box
and then I thought, oh dear,
this is a book somewhere.
And it took me two
years of just thinking
about Blerk the swamp monster to try
to figure out what the story was.
So, that's why.
Thank you.
What's your other question, honey?
>> Why, when those babies were
filled with stars they grew bigger?
>> Kelly Barnhill: Oh, because
starlight is very special, you know?
Stars come to us from a very,
very, very far ways away.
And so, as it moves through space
and time, it becomes kind of blessed
in the world of this story.
So, that's why.
Good question!
Next question, yeah.
>> Was there anyone in
your life who inspired you
to write the character of Luna?
>> Kelly Barnhill: Of
Luna, really good question.
So, one of the things
that I liked about Luna is
that she is a prickly girl.
She is impatient and sometimes
frustrated and has a lot
of questions and knows that people
aren't giving her straight answers
all the time.
And it fills her with, she's
motivated by her own hunger to know,
as well as her own tenderness
of the people around her,
as well as her frustration
of not knowing things.
And for me, I mean, Luna reminds
me a lot of my own daughters.
She also reminds me
a little bit of me.
And because i sometimes,
when I was here age,
when I was eleven I
had a temper, too.
And so, so, I see a lot
of myself in her, too.
So, great question.
Thank you.
Ah, yeah.
>> What is your favorite
poem in the book?
>> Kelly Barnhill: Oh, well, I mean,
probably my favorite poem is the
very first one that Glurk gave me,
it is the last poem in the book,
the heart is built of starlight
and time, a pinprick of
longing, lost in the dark.
An unbroken cord linking the
infinite to the infinite.
I wish upon your heart,
and that wish is granted.
Meanwhile, the world spins.
Meanwhile, the universe expands.
Meanwhile, the miracle of the heart
is realized in the miracle of you.
So. Anyway.
Thank you.
Yeah.
>> I have two questions.
My first question is, who is your
favorite character in the book?
>> Kelly Barnhill: Oh, you know,
I would say probably my favorite
character in the book is Fyrian.
Which, I have to be
careful about saying that,
because I almost wrote him out.
And, because I was worried that
he was a disruptive character,
and I was worried that I would
have to take him out of the story.
And so, I sent my editor
an email saying,
I'm worried that I might
have to get rid of Fyrian.
And she wrote back in one second,
and she said, oh, don't you dare!
So, I had to figure out
how to like make him,
I had to change some things in the
book to make his character work.
And so, as a result, I feel this
great tenderness towards him,
because I had to work so
hard to keep him there.
So. Anyway, that's probably why.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> Where did you get the
inspiration for Fyrian?
>> Kelly Barnhill: For Fyrian?
You know, I, I think that,
you know, I mean, partially,
what's funny about
Fyrian is that he,
I wrote him before
I got our new dog.
We have a dog who's
a black labrador.
His name is Serious Black.
He is nothing like his namesake.
He would not last 5
minutes in Askaban.
But, but it's funny
because there's so much
of my dog that is like Fyrian.
He just wants, he wants to be
part of the group all the time.
And but Fyrian is also a lot like
this kid I used to babysit for,
actually, who thought he was much
bigger, like he was this tiny,
tiny little kid, but he would always
tell people he was 7 feet tall.
So, he comes a little
bit from that kid, too.
Great question.
Yes?
>> What made you choose the ending?
>> Kelly Barnhill: Oh,
really good question.
You know, I'm not even really sure.
I mean, for me, I don't do a
lot of planning with my books.
The ending is the ending because
that simply was the ending, right?
The, usually I can't
see any other way.
So, you follow the
story where it leads,
and sometimes that
simply is what it is.
So, so yeah, I was happy about
it, though, because I don't
like endings that are too neat.
And I wanted, because in the end,
I think, I think that there are no,
like, heros and villians, that
there's only, you know, good choices
and bad choices and that all of us
have, it's incumbent to all of us
to make good choices, right?
And so, even people
who are villanous
in the story have the opportuinty
and have the responsibility
to make a good choice, right?
So, anyway, there, most
of my books end in sort
of similarly sort of ambiguous ways.
So. Yes?
>> What was your reaction
for getting the call
from the Newberry Honors?
>> Kelly Barnhill: Well!
[Laughter] Well!
So, when you, here's
the thing that happens
when you win a Newberry Award.
They call you at 5:00
in the morning.
And some people, some people have
an inkling that it might be them,
they might get that call.
And so, they are very smart and
they actually, like, wake themselves
up so they don't sound like
a moron when they talk.
But what happened to me is
that I had no idea at all,
so I was deep asleep,
and then my phone rang.
And it was really loud, because
my kids had, a few days before,
changed the ring tone of my phone to
be the theme song to Wonder Woman,
the old '70s TV show
And it's all, you know,
like lots of like '70s funk.
It's a really great theme song.
And so, that was the sound that
woke me up at 5:00 in the morning.
And I answered the phone and
I didn't know who it was,
because it wasn't a
number that I knew.
And I was worried that something
terrible had happened to,
like, a family member.
Because, I'm Irish Catholic.
I've got a million family members.
But you never know.
And so, I answered the phone, and
on the other side was this room full
of super cheerful librarians who
were, like, they were so excited,
and they're cheering for me.
It took me a while to, like,
actually process what
they were saying.
And all i could say in return
was a bunch of nonsense.
Just garbledy nonsense.
Ladies and gentlemen, I have
a sign that says Wrap it Up.
Which means I can't listen
to all your questions,
and I want to hear
all of your questions.
However, those of you who still
have questions, if you want them
to be answered, I want
to answer them.
So, there's two ways to do that.
One, I am going to go over to the
signing line, so you can come over
and ask me your questions then.
Also, my website is
Kelly Barnhill dot com.
The contact button goes
straight to my email.
You ask me whatever you want,
and I will answer it for you.
Okay? Guys, you were amaxing.
What a great audience!
A pluses to everybody!
[ Applause ]